pas le temps je suis pressé et tu
devrais pas rester là ça énerve mon père
je viens pourtant de me faire fondre à
la dernière mode c'est bientôt les
nouvelles floraisons et il faut que tu
sois ma cavalière regarde ça je suis
grand et j'ai des fleurs qui me poussent
sous les bras je sens vachement bon
pour toi ma reine
désolé petit on n'est pas compatible
[Musique]
oh non faut que j'y aille s'il te plaît
viens à la fête des floraisons avec moi
tu
restes tout bien sûr parce que j'y
trouve tout ce qu'il me faut
[Musique]
en plus tu vois bien que cette ville n'a
pas été conçue pour les êtres de feu
désolé mais je préfère raser les murs
plutôt que de traverser ce pont
[Musique]
salut ça va vieille branche comme dans
un rêve tu sais ce rapport que je viens
de t'envoyer de Fire Town je m'apprêtais
à le transférer à Madame cumulus avant
de me faire traiter contre les
moisissures
dis-lui ce que tu viens de me dire sur
ton père et sa déception non c'est
personnel mais ça m'a touché il pourrait
ressentir la même chose son père sera
sûrement
sur mon truc super déçu ça suffit tu
pourrais même avoir
oh Google qu'est-ce que tu fais mais le
plus grand c'est que si son père ne peux
pas partir à la retraite ce sera la
faute de
je crois que je vais rentrer plus tôt
aujourd'hui
vous inspectez vraiment l'alimentation
aux dernières nouvelles oui alors
inspectez ça
oui ça me semble parfait
[Musique]
tu vois il se régale